[موسيقى]
هذه المجتمع مالتنا العراقي نحنا نشوف
المراه يعني مساعده يعني اكثر من الرجال
يعني هي لان دائما
تشوفه يعني تصير لمساعده اكثر من الرجال
الرجل
لما حار من نوع الرجل الحساسه الى درجه
يعني ما يتوقعها اي انسان اكثر من المرض
عند ملاحظه المشاعر بالنسبه
للرجل وللمراه لاحظ ان هنالك اختلاف ما
بين المراه والرجل بهذا الموضوع على
اعتبار ان المراه همم طبيعه ملامحها او
تقاسيم الوجه هي تظهر اكثر مصداقيه من
الرجل بالتحديد لغه العيون واذا تلاحظ
سيكولوجيه العينيه تكشف ما بداخل النفس
المشاعر تكون عند الرجال وعندي النساء
اكبر بعض الاحيان الرجل يشعر انه هو
مشاعره اكثر تجاه المراه والمراه بعد
تكون هي تقرا مشاعر الرجل من خلال احاسيسه
ومشاعرها اتجاه الشخص الموجود
[موسيقى]